never got through a good Block in front by
Lindstrom he shaking his left hand but he
appears to be just fine Tanner Pearson over the
Blue Line his wrist shot kicked toide Monahan on
the rebound couldn't get a clean shot Pearson
slings it in front nobody home all the way to
Center but the Good Vibes in this building winning
that Stanley Cup with Tampa Bay a few years ago
Harry panar Evans weak shot right on gly Harry
panar in front tried to cash inight and marstrom
was there kevich back door feet Anderson shoots
and he just missed as he had the goal late in
the loss of the Canucks on Sunday Harbor Jacky
Sosi Co Coffield backand and that quick little
release Coffield on markstrom mat Christian
aor little s for Coffield to the forand pops
three Cole Cofield couple Great Looks early good
chances early for Montreal they're on the power
play when we come back Conor zeri heeds it across
reot up high and cadria good shot and handled by
Mono cadri again on the buck far boards he'll
drop it off Coffield trying to steal Bigs zor
off gets in his way but Montreal controls sovi
couldn't handle the pass Calgary shoots it right
back in mat looking for Coffield picked up at the
line Rasmus Anderson R shot mono couldn't glove
it down s csky battling for position Anderson took
it away one time drive off the stick and into the
corner here's weager at the line for Calgary
weager looking at options still with it wrist
shot wide he wanted to tip in [Applause] front
picked up by Dylan dub creating some space WR
shot blocker stop monmo good pressure here from
Calgary little push in the offensive zone and the
halves can't clear Anderson again on the buck he
shoots in the tip just wide duay in front Calgary
getting some fresh legs though that's Huer jumping
on the ice the Quebec native Jonathan hubero six
straight games with a point versus Montreal and as
Glenn mentioned a guy desperate to get heated up
here Anderson again on the buck shoots right
patch stop another blast and that misses the
mark hit by dorak comes fre to Cole Coffield with
some space Coffield for slowski slowski Coffield
shoots oh what a stop the pass wasn't right on the
stick he still got the shot away the backand pass
it's not perfect but that proves to be even more
of a problem for Jacob marstrom CFI will handle
it off can't be soon enough for Josh Anderson
and when he gets one he's probably going to get
three four or five just open up the floodgates
for him as cadri around of vorac cadry spinning
shooting score nazam cryy the ice breaker here
in the second period it's one nothing [Applause]
Calgary tender to read on this PL Arbor Jacky
tries to close the gap here lindstrom's on the
pinch watch Jacky just gets back on his heels
a little bit it's just a spin around move and a
blind shot by nzm cadri towards the net Dvorak
chips it behind the net slowski picks it up
slowski dorak lindstrm and shoot
score Gustaf lindstrm first as
a Montreal Canadian levels
it up at [Applause] [Music]
one go right back to work I slavski makes a good
play Down Low Christian D'Or with a sneaky pass
over the back of the net this may have gone
off Rasmus Anderson Lindstrom gets it towards
the net but watch the vorx pass go literally over
the back on the far side of the net catching the
goal tender by surprise off the boards tough
pass right to Suzuki with Evans Suzuki short
handed for Evans and the left pass of marstrom
denies Jake Evans he's looking at it right now
the same thing you are he picks the puck up
watch the patience he's on the backand he's
Measuring Up left wing for cadri he gets hit
by lindstam who's have a impact on this game
tonight oh that is a hard hit gatri in front
PA pistle tonight by Mono we'll go back on
the attack back hand for Suzuki with some
Pace he's got new hook Anderson in shoots
off the post are you kidding is going to score
another goal in the National Hockey League it's
just her matter of win but Nick Suzuki a play
that Anderson started Baron at the end of a
shift he'll head off for a change oh lindol was
crafty though stretch pass PA pistol shoots and
mono he felt it weager off the draw cross for
Anderson for posle back to Anderson in front
Zer scores Conor Zer Johnny on the spot bangs
it in and Calgary's got the lead again it's two
and breaking down the defense from the top and
then an excellent pass by Anderson so here are
the two defenseman there's the back and forth
to the high slot marasmus Anderson Just Hits
Conor's are right on the tape in front of the
net Lindstrom jams it back in for Monahan Shan
Mahan behind the net Monahan Lindstrom again
try to double down in the game and markstrom
got enough up high D Simone gave it away
to Gallagher Gallagher Monahan wrap job in
tight and markstrom found it good deception
by Monahan and he had to get there every bit
as quick as he did a a turnover by Simone on
the Gallagher's tape and a quick little dish
to monan just the two wins thus far thre
it over to borac in front Cole Coffield
denied markstrom stoned him Nick Suzuki head up
Anderson one of the onetime found on a Caufield
R shot loose in fronts as Coffield a great
look and Monahan couldn't cash in front of
markstrom e Simone backed up by
ritka roska gave it away though right to mat he
can't clear quick strike rebound score buried
in front battling along the boards here and
it just popped free for a split second Mike
Madison in full control of the puck lias Lindholm
steps in front of the clearing pass turns around
blindly fires it on net just Ms thinks he's
got it by him here forside to the [Applause]
goal leore suek and James Tobias on the call and
so M Aon remains at 99 career NHL goals good
challenge by Mar St Louis and the coaching
staff here iosi his countryman roska hits him but
Montreal still controls Mattis in rot off the post
Anderson again in front providing that screen he
might have got a tip on that Coffield quickly for
Suzuki next Suzuki walks it in making moves Mahan
in front Suzuki chip drop tried to bank it in off
markstrom cadri out of the box dvorac through
Center harar towards it D'Or nearly chips it
in cutting in Coffield on the puck he'll jam
it for Suzuki 7 seconds left in the miner to
Gallagher Monahan and Suzuki in the corner Giger
on his skates ready to come out Monahan in front
Anderson oh what a club are you kidding Anderson
stopped by markstrom Monahan and that big leather
glove comes out of nowhere and snares that
and Anderson just rolls his head back perfect
positioning what a stop mahad on
the puck Shan Monahan threads it
across 6 seconds left Anderson farbs
WR shot Monahan picks it up in front
go field whipped on it one last
try through the crease and gager